um you can see I've already begun my
solution and I didn't say it but this is
part of what happens in that's it
you guys have drawn like dozens of the
ignite and you know it's a useful
treated to solving all kinds of problems
that some of these are on the board in
fact really all of these problems can be
solved out of this one little diagram
just why it's so on it's so powerful
okay now I'm not quite finished your
tree might look a bit different to mine
but I heard we all ended at the same
spot you should have found four numbers
at the ends of all the branches did you
get the same four numbers I did yeah so
you can see and this is why I tend to do
once I always finish a tree I get a new
color and I'm highlight I circled all
other times
okay I like to read it in another
product it's the soil makes it stand out
seven is a prime number
now what do I do there's our circle book
right how do I get those and answer the
question what is the prime factorization
of 60 what am I going to write yes two
squared that's just right there yeah
times three times five perfect okay so
this this big PR this is the prime
factorization of 60 you might want to
write that down if you go to bat the
first time you like that we use this
phrase before this is what is being
asked for but I said what is the prime
factor there is now this happens on a
bounce quite a lot when it says well
look you've got this down you can use it
in all these different ways so we're
gonna do number two in order to get the
highest common factor I'm going to need
some more factor trees for these notes
now they're pretty quick on wonder if
you can help me 42 sounds to me like six
times
seven very good seven these Prime's you
can't do anything else with that I can
do something good seeks that what's that
three you can either come in - okay so
just like before I'm going to get my
enemy color app and I'm going to circle
all of the primes okay so what am I
going to do with that
like what's what's the usefulness of
this and how does it drive that anybody
give me a suggestion turtle very good I
want to know the biggest up I possibly
can that will be divided into this and
divided into this without any remains
that's why the factors like to a senate
i spot a 2 + 2 and s 1 a 3 and a 3
that's all the color factors I can't use
two twos there's only one over here
right can't use that five because one
over here you can't use a seven just not
over there so that's it so I'm going to
say therefore the highest common factor
of 60 and 42 you see so really really
condense a brilliant way of saying it
the highest common factor of these two
numbers is 2 times 3 that's the $2 you
taught me about the gym of course
6 and you can check it 6 miles divided
into both - ok Part B again we need one
more tree we're gonna do something a bit
different as well
56 yet 56 can someone tell me what
they're divided 56 into two and 28 okay
what can I do that someone else who
didn't know missus anything yeah Yeah
right
yeah look at you 14:02 okay so now
listen 14 yes senator - Thank You Abby
okay so now done everything is primed
one last time for good measure I'm gonna
set the loam opponents one two three
four okay this is a bit tricky when
we're trying to combine all these
different skills together so see if we
can understand this one button to come
up this other what something different
I want a lowest common multiple so how
am I going to use these factors this
time you want to give me a suggestion
Louis comments was tricky and we do very
recently you gotta join make a
suggestion before I talk it is it's a
tricky question what was full of
multiple right so for example the lowest
common multiple let's think of an easy
example the ones you guys have seen
before of three and five right it's 15
degree with that like 15 - multiple of
three it's about to pull of five another
way of saying that is 3 + 5 of Bertha
factors of 15 so I want all of these
factors to be my lowest moment okay okay
so and this is where um this is very fun
little bit but I'm gonna highlight up
this way to is not a multiple of 56 or
60 because we are looking off we're
thinking about factors right so 2 is a
factor of 40 to exist but it's not
multiple the multiples of 60 are like
well 60 and then what's the next one 120
and then the next one's 180 really 240
and so on so multiples means you as an
internist you multiply or whatever again
or as fact as me you define that's
different operations that make sense to
be easy to confuse but putting it
together helps us it so what I want is
to find a number which has all of these
factors here as well as all of these
factors here because that makes sense so
the star with Tunes my lowest common
multiple of 56 and 60 how many twos am I
going to need it tell me - yeah okay I'm
going to need at least two cuz look I
got two there right but when I never
look over
how many trees are there here there are
three and I need all of them right so
that the best the another is too cute
the next five not two is three 2083
one is three
I do don't I right there's a three here
okay
so I have used the to the tariqa to
there I've covered these twos as well
because they're been heated in there and
now one three as well write that down
that's coming and you can see what's
left right you see the notice I have
underlined yet fine hasn't been
underlined so I need that and seven
years have been on the one so I need
that does that make sense
this is a big dump I didn't even know
what these yet can we try to work it out
together do you think we could do it
yeah do you already have the odds on
okay before we get there let's see if we
can unpack it together this is eight
what's three times five yeah
fifteen minutes seven okay which part
should i do first
what's 8:15
that's the same as four thirties isn't
it
four birdies what support they used
that's yeah it'll be twenty hundred
twenty okay all Loomis there who do
twenty times seven
let's just forget about the zero for a
second seven times 12 because sometimes
12 7 times 12 is 84 so then I had the
zero back done that was a significant
laughter okay doesn't work will 56 go
into that but you can check if you want
I won't do it right now but it's easy to
check and I can do the same for 60
pretty sure it'll work out okay so do
you any want to attempt the challenge
yeah yeah
ah okay so we're here trailer workout is
a bit of a difference between working
out the common factor and the common
multiple when you've got to cover
multiple you want the smallest number
you possibly can right I don't want it
too big I want it to be little so I put
in three tubes to include all of these
guys whatever gonna be here three twos
is even more than two tubes right I've
already covered this I don't need to
multiply by the war tunes I've already
got enough to cover this number and
enough to cover this number right so for
example if I just multiply this by two
it's still gonna be able to season I
don't need to multiply by five - I only
need three so this is that getting the
small stuff up there is this one is
about getting the highest number and
they're probably on both lists so they
do work a little bit differently that's
why I was challenging okay did anyone
try this
did anyone try the challenge okay I just
gotta quickly show you and if you're
curious more about the details I will
show you a bit later on remember I said
just a minute that this guy here and the
treatment came wrong it's the key to
pull these questions yeah watch this 60
is 2 squared times 3 times 5 every
square number like say a hundred just
quickly do the prime factorization of
hundreds and someone suggests we know
what this leads to yet
and I can keep going on because he's out
trying what goes after this really two
and five and then you have to go to a
five again don't you okay
so therefore a hundred is two squared
times 5 squared ok let's try another one
how about 36 basics that's a sway number
as well what's the square off yeah
6 right so I've got six and six what
does 6 go into 3 & 2 very good 2 3 so
therefore this is 2 squared times 3
square look at that for a second
3,600 you try with any square number you
like when you do the factorization you
Handy's end up with everything squared
that makes sense it's a square so have a
look at this this is square but these
two are not squared right so if I
multiply by an extra 3 and an extra 5 do
you see that'll make it 2 squared 3
squared 5 squared
do you see that so that's what's this
what's the signature that's 15 isn't it
so what happens what is 16 times 15 16
times 15 15 16
it's awesome hot 60 times 50 60 times 15
yeah actually I think it is easily 900
900 900 a sweat about it isn't it it's I
think it's 30 squared okay now you can
get big enough than that but that's the
smallest one that's the smallest square
you can possibly get that is a multiple
of 60 so anyway these are the kinds of
questions you know when we did those
problem-solving type things these are
the kinds of questions we get and you
can see you solve and in the same way to
lose insane